way bigger businesses than you have been
put out of business because of
technology shifts when I invested in
uber five years ago I called my dad's
Russian friends in LA they came to this
country in 78 79 they were dead broke
they lived in studio apartments they
drove taxi cabs for 2-3 bucks an hour
hustled their way work every hour no
Saturday and Sunday for 20 years built
up a business didn't buy anything saved
all their money eventually bought their
own car eventually had four or five guys
or girls underneath them built a
business had the American Dream finally
got into their 50s and 60s worked every
goddamn minute to get there and now
we're gonna kind of like enjoy it a
little bit and then uber came along and
so I called modoch and Vladimir and
these guys have said hey Vlad me right
now and said Vlad I've got good news and
bad news you know good news is you know
you've done well and America is the
greatest country in the world bad news
is you might be in trouble and literally
the three of them verbatim we're all
like that's nice boy chick we'll be okay
so what you're telling me is they're
gonna take a phone and hit a button and
the car is gonna come very good very
good I'll talk to you later
that's a funny story and I say it funny
here's what's not funny every one of
those three guys businesses have been
slaughtered absolutely slaughtered all
of their businesses now that they're
trying to sell are literally worth 15
cents on the dollar of what it was worth
just four years ago